la cft eu avec ses 66 buts de peu fait
ressortir qu'une trentaine
donc il en manque une 30 donc nous avec
nos quinze bus nous prévoyons de
renforcer le réseau
et puis de faire la continuité du
service public ce qui paraît logique
alors bon nous attendons nous avons fait
des réunions en préfecture mairie
plusieurs femmes épisode avec monsieur
alfred qui dit oui tout le temps il dit
oui la dernière réunion de la tête donc
du 28 septembre 2018 dans lequel il
disait que le 3 octobre il mettra trois
places nous le tractons nous sommes le
24 aujourd'hui et on entend tout on
entend tout evenos où le média et manque
de but simon début juillet nous avons 15
juges qui sont là qui ne travaillent pas
dans des accords qui sont prévus
aujourd'hui on veut ni cui on veut un
écuyer au niveau des dates on vous dit
on disait on dit qu'il faut des qui nous
rencontrent avant qui continue parce
qu'en fait quand le problème qui se pose
aujourd'hui essaient de résoudre à faire
le réseau repartir mais le zoo repas en
commun avec des bus qui sont malades
les bus sont malades mais nous nous
avons des bus qui sont debout
aujourd'hui pourquoi ces bus là ne font
pas la quantité de services publics ce
qui a été demandé déjà aussi par
martinique transport depuis le mois
d'avril par document de presse